let's go to
somebody you've known well somebody who
is
who's also a drug smuggler it's very
seal
who is barry seal how did you meet him
bear she was a friend of mine
uh murray and i and the children went
down in uh
honduras and we went up uh lake azul
i believe it was and was looking at a
ranch to buy i was looking for something
central america where i'd have a halfway
place
oh it was lovely we stayed up there for
some days and our clothes got
muddy and we went in the river and all
kind of thing so we got to san pedro
sula
and uh was going back to new orleans
so went to to the cleaners to get our
clothes and most all of them was in
there
and they go senor they'll be ready
tomorrow morning we're not ready now
well the plane leaves it
nine o'clock or whatever so
i told murray to for her and the
children to go into the airport because
it'd be
easier for one just on a standby flight
so i went to the
um laundromat for the clothes and they
were ready and
there was a pile up and i put them on my
back and got into taxiing the old taxi
would drive him with it and i'd give him
a hundred dollars to go faster and he
just blew his horn
more rapid
finally we got to the airport and i
jumped out and ran around
on the tarmac and here's a brand new 727
taxiing out oh no
so i'm waving to the pilot and he's a
young fella he waves back
then i see mari's face in the cockpit
and the nose goes down where he puts on
brakes
and he laughs and he puts some stairwell
out and i run for the stairwell and he
pulls it back up and goes like a
hitchhiker gonna pick you up and go go
again
then he put it out and i got on an old
crowd clapped and
i'm coming home with that load of
clothes
so i go way down in the middle and the
plane's full
and miriam my daughter's about nine
years old then
and she was sitting in the middle and by
the window was barry seal of course i
didn't know it
and i sat in the middle and uh we took
off and
the wheels come up with clunk and then i
got up about five thousand feet we had a
little click link
and she said what was that daddy i said
he just turned on his autopilot
and that fella reached over and i looked
at him i said he looks like cia or fbi
something he ain't supposed to be here
clear blue eyes
gentleman-looking man and he
he said you fly these things i said i
got a few hours mister he said i fly
them too or something other than they
said my name barry seal he reached over
near him and shook hands
and we got to talking and i thought
there's no choice of seats on this it's
just open seating so
but i don't believe him one bit
and he started talking about he just got
out of jail that morning just got
out of prison and i said uh-huh
and he told me he had been a pilot with
a twa in this another
and uh told me what what he was for and
so we had a nice chunk
conversation with a couple hours to new
orleans i didn't believe him
yeah so he got off in front of us and
what a crowd of people
to meet him an old mother and a wife and
little children
hanging on to him crying and hugging and
kissing him i said
he was telling the truth
so i reached over and gave him a little
piece of paper i had mario to write it
out with our address i said barry i
might have some work for you
was he in jail for he got caught with
100 kilos of cocaine
and a small plane and so he served a
year
and that was from colombia i don't know
where he comes from he got called in
honduras probably refueling
but he'd he'd been in prison down here
before for bringing explosives to the uh
cuban countries and he lost his job with
the airlines
and then later on i found out he was
xcia and george bush seniors protege and
had a thousand parachute jumps and was
there
he was a hot shot there's a million
questions
i want to ask here but um maybe can we
linger on
a little bit longer what was your
relationship with him like
you you were a drug smuggler he's a drug
smuggler
um your friends
how often do you guys talk how often do
you work together
what was the relationship like well back
up and just finish where i started off
there
he uh i i gave him a thanks bear i may
have some work for you i know i got some
work for you
and uh i said come out santa barbara
and so i don't know a week or two later
he flew out and
went to our house and stayed with us a
couple of days and i had a
almost brand new uh arrow commander 690b
that thing was turboprop and it was hot
it's the hottest thing i'd ever had so i
said
let's go barry let's see what you can do
i'm sorry i said that we got about 9 000
feet
and he was like one of them blue angel
pilots he wrung that thing out
yeah you know that's enough and then um
he did the falling leaf
that's where you cut the engines in the
plane folds from side to side i saw bob
hoover do that in the air show once and
that's the only person i ever saw do it
and i was my hand was white knuckle
hanging onto the seat
he shut off the engine yeah he shut off
the engines and landed flying
side by side like this how do you
explain that was he just
uh a wild man or was he sufficiently
skilled to wear sufficiently skilled
absolutely he knew what he was doing i
can get a plane from one spot to another
and i guess i'm known as a good pilot
but that guy
it was an aerobatic
[Laughter]
so anyway he stayed with us a couple of
days and then i told him i said this
plane needs uh
needs tank and i guess i got some work
done in colombia needs to come back to
louisiana
and i need 2 500 mile range he said i
got somebody in mina arkansas to do that
and keep the mouse shut
so i gave him 10 000 and he flew away
and in a few days he called me and says
come to my house in
baton rouge so i went out to his house
in baton rouge and
i stayed with him for a few days and
that plane was tanked i mean beautiful
from
stem to stern i could went from bolivia
to canada with him
so uh he was then i hired him to fly
and uh he was funny i paid him a million
dollars a trip
i think two thousand dollars a kilo so
about a million ultra
and i didn't get paid until they the
people received it they had to ship it
to
chicago and new york and then the money
come back so it was a couple of
two or three weeks pipeline well i
always had to pay him
before before he'd go again i mean and
he barely ached
i mean he had moaning wrong so uh
one time i uh i gave him a million
dollars and i put it in the box real
nice
so how big is a box that contains a
million dollars so we're talking about
hundred dollar bills hundred dollars
it's not very big you can put it in a
large briefcase
it weighs exactly 10 kilos each each hbo
weighs a gram so you can weigh your
money
and almost get it exactly 10 20
something pounds is a million dollars
22 pounds 20 pounds a hundred dollar
bills
but a hundred and one dollar bills just
one ton 2 200 pounds
we didn't even accept them were you the
one that introduced berry seal to uh
pablo escobar
no i didn't introduce him at all and uh
he and i our deal was that you don't
meet my people i mean we just got across
you working for me
to fly the airplanes so he wanted these
panther conversions cost 400 000
each with a storm scope and radar so i
want anything you want
what's that mean sorry to interrupt
panther conversions uh panther
conversion was a
these people called panther they took
everything out from the firewall the
instruments and all them converted them
and put q-tip propellers on them
full-bladed and you
very quiet and the cia developed those
in southeast asia
for running behind the lines and that's
where barry had flown those things so he
knew about him
so hey that's what he wanted and that's
what we got him
how does that connect to pablo and so he
worked for you
and you got those upgrades i think he
flew about 30 loads for me and then i
got arrested
and was better for everything in the
world
got 35 years sentence but let me back up
a little bit
barry uh was our friend
uh mari and i both ran we should pause
real quick
and say mari is uh uh your wife
and we'll hopefully she'll uh we'll
convince her to join us in a little
in in a little bit she's the love of
your life and sort of she uh
weaves in and out of many of these
stories that you tell
yes she was there she was behind the
scenes but i kept her out of it
completely
and then also you mentioned miriam as a
as a your daughter
yes rhett our son was a was a baby yeah
and uh i remember we went out to the
festival
was my favorite restaurant in carl
gables oh god it was good
and barry knew about it anyhow we went
out to dinner and
uh so we came back and there was no
rooms
so very well would spend the night with
us so he goes to our hotel room with him
we got two
two big beds in the omni hotel and he
lays over there gets down to his stripy
undershorts and his t-shirt and he puts
a baby up on his belly and gives him the
bottle said ain't that good red oh my my
and he just feeds the baby
we laugh and talk and that's how close
we were
that we could all stay in a hotel room
together
and would you say he's a good man a
wonderful man
a gentleman southern gentleman just
he's looked after his mother his family
everybody around him
everybody loved barry he just had a he
had a little
little smile on his face always so you
got arrested
and then what happened to barry well
barry knew the
the people that uh unloaded
of course he sent the cars down all that
so he met
the unloader guy named lito louis carlos
bustamante
of venezuelan and uh so he's just kept
on flying
but he uh yeah i believe he had three of
my airplanes at 400
a piece and they owe me some money well
he collected a lot of that and
gave murray the money and put it in his
safe and took her to his house and
after i got arrested sent a lawyer in
you got me the best lawyer in the
country
albert krieger he was head of the
defense team for all america
wonderful man
you